nació y creció en un barrio obrero de
Estambul receta Jeep erdoan hijo de una
familia migrante del mar Negro vivía una
infancia sin lujos y llegó incluso a
vender comida en la calle pero una de
sus decisiones le cambió la vida para
siempre su creencia islámica que le
llevó a afiliarse al partido de
salvación nacional islamista y lo
catapultó hasta la alcaldía de Estambul
en 1994 con una agenda Clara Apoyar el
islamismo en el país algo que le costó
una condena de 10 meses de prisión
fui declarado culpable solo por leerme
un poema y me gustaría acusar que esto
es una tragedia y una vergüenza para
nuestra historia jurídica
[Aplausos]
tras cuatro meses en prisión y la
prohibición de su partido decidió
alejarse del ala más dura del islam y
fundar un partido más moderado el akp
con el que ganó las elecciones generales
de 2002 y consiguió convertirse en el
primer Primer Ministro islamista de
Turquía en 2003
dado que la mayoría de la población
turca es musulmana el éxito Turco en el
proceso de la Unión Europea será un gran
ejemplo para otros países musulmanes y
mostrará como la democracia puede
convivir muy bien con el islam
con el inicio de la era Eduard llegó el
crecimiento económico y la modernización
ante el país pero también los altibajos
y las polémicas en torno a su figura los
críticos lo acusaban de ser a cada vez
más autoritario y De no respetar a los
Derechos Humanos
no se puede tratar a las mujeres y a los
hombres igual porque su naturaleza es
diferente
sus mandatos como Primer Ministro
erdwardán se convirtió en presidente en
dos mil a catorce de nuevo con una gran
promesa una nueva constitución y situar
a Turquía entre las diez de economías
del mundo no obstante en julio de 2016
un intento de golpe de estado que se
saldó con casi 300 muertos hizo
tambalear su gobierno Y aunque en 2017
ganó un referendo que le otorgaba más
poderes su base electoral ha cambiado en
los últimos años y esta vez no se sabe
si el fanatismo en torno a su figura
será suficiente para perpetuarse en el
poder